the 66th international motor show or iaa
has opened in frankfurt this year's
motto is mobility connects about 1100
exhibitors from 39 countries are
presenting their newest products
including 219 world premieres
the trend to cars with off-road
capability continues unbroken
just before the show opened jaguar
presented what may be the show's most
spectacular images
with the first suv in its portfolio the
british car maker aims for a world
record and had the new jaguar f pace
loop the loop
a powerful performance and a clear
message this car aims to turn the suv
world upside down f-base
is a crossover
and therefore it is a combination of
people who want to have the agility the
sportiness the drivability but also the
functionality
and the possibility to go off-road
with the e-tron quattro concept audi
shows how it intends to develop its suv
family the new machine is conceived as
an all-electric car
aerodynamic components on the front
sides and rear ensure optimal airflow
around the vehicle
audi chairman rupert stadler says the
e-tron is a statement about the design
language of the future the car's new
fuel cell technology will give it a
range of more than 500 kilometers the
company plans to bring the e-tron to
market in 2018.
seot-2 has been hard at work on the suv
theme its concept car the leon cross
sport combines three doors and off-road
capability in a new way
mateus rabba says the cross sport
provides a glimpse of the leon's
potential
and seahawk wants to see how people
respond to this concept car he considers
it a fantastic car and wants to see it
go into production
the hyundai i20 active also looks like
an suv
hyundai's managing director in germany
says it's two centimeters higher and has
higher seats and metal cladding on the
sides it's a car for people who want to
go off-road sometimes it broadens the
company's pallet to target new customers
lexus ties the suv to environmental
awareness the hybrid rx-450h is powered
by a 3.5 liter v6 engine with direct
fuel injection despite the system's 230
kilowatts lexus rates consumption at
only 5.2 liters per 100 kilometers
lex's general manager for germany ferry
france says the car has been enlarged
and given more legroom to meet customers
wishes it has completely new navigation
and safety technology
when it comes to hybrid technology
toyota's prius has been leading the pack
for 18 years at the iaa the japanese
prius's fourth generation has its world
premiere fuel efficiency is 18 greater
than its predecessors and its whole body
design is new
toyota spokesman dirk broyer says the
prios has a new platform strategy the
toyota new global architecture or tnga
different models are built from the same
range of parts
of
another successor to a bestseller is
vw's new generation of the tiguan based
on the company's modular transverse
matrix platform vw has big plans for the
tiguan the gte offers a sneak peek of an
electric version a sporty r-line model
is ready to go into mass production
vw's head of powertrain development
heights jacob neuser says the company
will respond to market signals and he
can imagine a sporty derivative will do
well too
volkswagen is also rolling out the caddy
alltrack an all-purpose vehicle
available both as a sedan and a
hatchback
skoda's flagship the superb has been
given more space inside here at the iaa
the checks are showing their new station
wagon version
head of skoda germany points out the
completely new design language the car
is full of innovative technology
assistance systems the latest
infotainment lots of room and it comes
with skoda's persuasive price to
performance
opel's astra by contrast has gotten
smaller and more compact and yet inside
the completely newly developed
generation gives passengers more space
and the astra has shed about 200
kilograms
bmw's theme at the iaa is
electrification from the 2 series
through the 3 series to the 7 series
which is now being offered in a plug-in
hybrid version the 740le
it's rated at only 2.1 liters of fuel
per 100 kilometers
mini is celebrating the premiere of the
club men which isn't that many at all
bmw board member peter schwarzenbauer
says the club man behind him is at the
upper limit of what can still count as a
minute
at 4.25 meters it's 43 centimeters
longer than the three-door mini the club
man has enough space for up to five
people and 360 liters of cargo and
folding the back seat down increases the
storage space to 1 250 liters
along with the facelift of the 911
carrera the mission e-concept car is the
eye catcher at the porsche stand it
provides a glimpse of the company's
first all-electric vehicle
porsche says the mission e has a
whopping 500 kilometer range
porsche ceo
expects the company to decide by the end
of the year to market a car like this
within a decade he says porsche's goal
is to offer a true electric drive sports
car that is better than the competition
in many areas
mercedes 2 is peering into the future
mercedes research executive thomas weber
says this is the fastest the company has
ever developed a show car the key was
digital processes computers also open
the way to such low air resistance
figures
the intelligent aerodynamic automobile
has set a record for cw value or drag
coefficient at 0.19
the extension in the rear gives it a
rocket tail look
these are spiders our car tester sasha
knopf describes the newest addition to
porsche's boxster series a spider a
spider is traditionally the crowning
achievement of a series and the boxster
spider is no exception it conveys the
essence of the porsche brand sportiness
and in this case
purism the spider is the lightest and at
the same time most powerful vehicle in
the boxster range the designers
concentrated on optimizing its driving
dynamics the two-seater mid engine
convertible has a manual six-speed
transmission
doing without luxuries saves weight and
the spider's lightness is palpable every
inch of the way
sasha notes that the driver sits very
low in the spider this lowers the center
of gravity providing additional
stability
unfortunately when you look behind you
you see almost nothing
especially due to the design of the new
trunk lid
the driver has to look past the two
humps and really stretch his neck
the 3.8 liter engine comes from the
carrera s and generates 276 kilowatts of
power the spider sprints from 0 to 100
in just 4.5 seconds porsche says the
boxster spyder's fuel consumption is 9.9
liters per 100 kilometers
in the sport plus mode the car
automatically double declutches
when you shift gears the engine briefly
revs up making the transition much
smoother and providing a special sound
experience
sasha says the porsche boxster spider's
purism is lovely but leads to an
annoying inconvenience the roof release
motor has been removed so you have to
put the top down by hand
first you must unlock the soft top on
both sides
then open the trunk
then push the top down into the trunk
and then you have to close the trunk and
turn down the latches separately on each
side
the boxster spider is a centimeter
longer and 11 millimeters lower than the
boxster gts
and the two humps called streamliners
located behind the roll bars are real
eye catchers
part of the spider's purism is that air
conditioning and a radio aren't standard
equipment they're optional extras
carbon fiber bucket seats are standard
and offer plenty of lateral support in
all situations
sasha says driving with the top down
lets you enjoy the sound of the 3.8
liter naturally aspirated engine when
you start the car you can set things so
that this button opens the flaps and
then the symphony begins
the boxster spider weighs in at just 1.3
tons the lightweight roof with its
unheated rear window
weighs 11 kilograms less than the motor
driven soft top found in other porsche
boxsters
the big trunk lid is made of aluminum
saving weight again the engine generates
up to 420 newton meters of torque that's
50 newton meters more than the boxster
gts
standard dynamic transmission mounts
give the spyder more stability on curves
targeted braking of the inside rear
wheel enhances steering precision
driving a porsche boxster spider is a
fashion statement in itself says sasha
so you need worry that the wind has
mushed your hair or a cap has flattened
it in the back the trunk loads 130
liters that's not a whole lot but
there's also some room up front
enough for a weekend getaway with your
sweetheart
sasha laments that fuel consumption is
so high 9.9 liters per 100 kilometers
which drives co2 emissions up to 230
grams per kilometer
maybe it's better to just look at this
car
than the drivers
one
the fourth generation mazda 2 has been
in german car showroom since february
the super mini which is also badged as
the mazda demio has shed its
conservative image
its new look is sleeker and sportier
mazda is targeting its m2 at younger
image conscious buyers looking to make a
self-confident appearance and here the
japanese model definitely delivers
its striking radiator grille and sharp
headlights are similar to those used in
the mazda 3 and mazda6 and have already
received a warm reception
likes the crisp 5-speed transmission and
good steering he says the suspension is
a little stiff but makes the mazda feel
safe and he stresses that the
four-cylinder engine runs smoothly
our test model has a 66 kilowatt
gasoline engine with 1.5 liters of cubic
capacity and 148 newton meters of torque
at a time when rough and ready
3-cylinder engines are all the rage the
mazda's quiet 4-cylinder power plant
makes for a pleasant change
things get a bit noisier at this test
site though here the mazda reveals some
weaknesses
on the obstacle course it under steers
at times and oversteers at others though
the esp kicks in and stabilizes things
and the braking distance of almost 39
meters for a car going 100 kilometers an
hour just isn't acceptable these days
unlike the car makers larger models the
mazda 2 has an analog speedometer still
the instruments have a modern look
the interior design boasts unusual
elements like these different air vents
the japanese model has a style all its
own with its usb ports and bluetooth the
multimedia system should satisfy the
demands of young buyers it can be
controlled centrally using a dial or
through the touchscreen
the trunk has a maximum cargo capacity
of 590 liters so there's plenty of room
for luggage unfortunately the high trunk
sill makes it hard to load and unload
when adac put the super mini to the test
it consumed 4.9 liters of fuel per 100
kilometers that's fairly thrifty though
not quite as good as the manufacturers
claimed average fuel consumption figures
of 4.5 liters
a man from adac says the new mazda 2's
fresh design will certainly attract many
potential buyers who will then be won
over by its inner virtues
our test car sells for just over 16 000
euros in germany pretty pricey for a
super mini but take the smaller gasoline
engine and forgo the trimmings and you
can pick up a mazda 2 for less than 13
000.
cars have made life easier for billions
of people
but can they do better
can they take on some routine car
related tasks
in the future they may be able to find a
spot in a parking garage entirely on
their own
vw presents v-charge
it allows the driver to use an app to
tell an e-golf to park itself
the user enters the time when they plan
to return and if desired a request that
the car be recharged the driver receives
a confirmation and leaves the car to
itself
it does the rest automatically
this is the future of driving you just
leave the car at the garage and go off
to an appointment or shopping and it
finds a parking spot automatically the
real sensation is that if a garage has a
charging station the car can
automatically go to recharge itself when
it's fully charged it frees up the
station and finds another parking spot
self-parking cars pose no danger to
other drivers or pedestrians cameras
ultrasound sensors and emergency braking
systems already developed for
conventional models have been adapted
for use in the v-charge project
the car can recognize pedestrians in its
path and come to a stop
with v-charge an electric car isn't
recharged in the usual way it parks
above an induction pad mounted in the
floor of the charging bay
infrastructure is also far more
efficient once charging is complete the
car equipped with v-charge automatically
makes way for another car to use the
station and finds another parking spot
the navigation system in the garage is
self-contained so a gps signal is
unnecessary for the car to find its own
way around
all self-parking cars will eventually
have to have access to high-resolution
3d maps of the participating garages to
find their way to the charging stations
without gps
vw calls its charging technology e-smart
connect
einhold eisenhover explains that the
charging station of the future will work
completely independently of humans the
car drives itself in and a robot arm
makes the connection it takes 19 to 30
minutes to reach 80 percent of the
battery capacity which the car detects
by itself and automatically makes the
station available or the robot can move
to another car
but why do we need a robot arm at all
the high voltages require thick cables
which are heavy and inflexible they may
be too cumbersome for some people to
handle but the robot arm has no problem
with it and the driver can go shopping
or have a cup of tea in the meantime
once the robot has accessed the car's
data it can locate the connector and
plug in the charging cable without human
help
a camera and a light help it to target
the socket with millimeter precision
but the robot can't open the recharging
cap itself
there are too many variations of shape
and position for it to remember
either the driver will have to open the
cap before handing over the car
or when the time comes it will have to
open itself electronically
when czech carmaker tatra rolled out the
t-87 in 1936 it was the avant-garde of
automotive design
it embodied the new vehicular philosophy
of the already well-established company
the steel body was self-supporting and
aerodynamic
the engine was air-cooled and
rear-mounted
at a time when most cars still looked
more like coaches the t-87 triggered an
automotive revolution
tatra collector ulrich
recalls the first time he ever saw a
t-87 it was not far from the former
tantra plant
his father was the founder of the german
tatra club every year before the season
began they would drive to the plant in
copranitsa
they took the opportunity to look over
the cars the club their owned
he walked into an old barn and the first
thing he saw was the rear of a t-87
he didn't know what it was but he said
to himself i've got to have this car
no something
but this hot mess
exactly
here
the progressive design was the work of
hans ledvinka and eric ubalaka lavinka
was an austrian engineer and a brilliant
designer who had worked for tatra since
1921.
levinka's credo was lightweight
construction and aerodynamic design
it broke with all the automotive
conventions of the time
now it looks a bit like something from
the 1930s science fiction series
spats over the rear wheels and the long
sloping rear were an early attempt at
streamlining
the striking fin down the back helped to
stabilize the car at high speeds
large air intakes kept the wind flowing
over the engine and back with the hot
air escaping through slits in the rear
lid
but it took a bit of practice to get
used to handling this rear heavy car
especially on wet pavement or at high
speeds driving expertise was essential
confirms that the t-87 fish tails all
too easily and unexpectedly there's no
warning of any kind the car may be
speeding along at a good clip and all of
a sudden off it goes
the cause is the t-87s poor weight
distribution
the two and a half liter rear mounted
engine had a light magnesium alloy block
but still it lay heavy on the rear axle
the v8 overhead cam was common among
racing and high performance cars of the
time
even with an output of just 75
horsepower the aerodynamic t-87 still
reached top speeds close to 150
kilometers per hour
in contrast to the body the interior
appeared quite conventional aside from a
few art deco touches
even with such a complete array of
instruments the tatra was easy to
operate
the sight lines were generous through
the big windshields
as long as the driver was looking
straight ahead
another feature unusual for the 1930s
was the manual sliding roof
the trunk in front carried two spare
wheels good to have along given the bad
roads of the time
the tatra t-87 was high-end avant-garde
so much so that only three thousand were
ever built
surviving communism the tatra company
produced cars until 1998 with
rear-mounted v8 engines to the very end
my
you